I'm a pretty-pretty me I'm a Republican
I think that's probably the first thing
people think when they think of my name
well that and this you know what joy I
really love their everyday open-minded
just trying to explain it okay not a fun
job but everybody hates I know you're
angry you're angry that Trump's
president like a lot of comments I read
every single day knows doing yelling at
me is gonna fix the problem and
apparently Megan McCain isn't feeling
the drama that comes with being on the
view now a source tells et that there is
some major tension between Megan who is
the more conservative voice on the panel
and the other ladies of the hit daytime
talk show specifically Joy Behar and
Whoopi Goldberg quote Megan also fights
back harder than the other hosts would
like she crosses so many lines because
she says exactly what's on her mind and
she doesn't care which of the hosts she
offends she clearly isn't trying to make
friends
excuse me earlier this month The Daily
Beast claimed that Megan was looking to
exit the show apparently feeling like a
caged animal on TV but a spokesperson
for the view told et that the show
expects all of the hosts to be back
quote for an epic year ahead
et source says that Megan doesn't want
to leave the show but she is struggling
with the drama quote Megan hates the
negative attention the show has brought
to her lately and every day feels like
she is going to war she always acts like
she wants to leave but that's just her
using her muscle because she's a draw
for the ratings in june megan enjoys on
air fight took a shocking turn when the
two disagreed over president Donald
Trump's supporters every day well
former view co-host Rosie O'Donnell
weighed in on the drama during a stop by
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
I do have some compassion for her
although I wish you wouldn't be mean to
Joy Behar who is you know like a living
legend and should be respected for no
other reason than she's the elder
statesman in the room all that said an
ABC spokesperson told ET on Wednesday
quote every day each of our smart and
talented co-hosts come to the table
prepared to explain and passionately
defend their individual takes on the hot
topics this is exactly what the view has
always been and will continue to be